la france et ses partenaires engagés
dans des missions de lutte contre le
terrorisme ont pris la décision de
retirer leur présence militaire au mali
ce retrait se traduira par la fermeture
des emprises de gossip de ménaka et de
gao il sera effectuée de manière
ordonnée avec les forces armées
maliennes et avec la mission des nations
unies au mali
[Musique]
la menace à laquelle les pays du sahel
de la région sont confrontés à un nom al
qaïda et des ch avec l'accord des
autorités nigériennes des éléments
européens seront repositionnées aux
côtés des forces armées nigériennes dans
la région frontalière du mali nous avons
convenu avec l'euro que la lutte conte
le sahel contre le terrorisme au sahel
ne saurait être la seule à faire depuis
africains et l'absolution consensus et
1,2 que un engagement a été renouvelée
de rester dans la région et de les
articuler le dispositif
[Musique]
la france a échoué dans tout cas dans la
pacification du cese c'est une évidence
le coeur du dispositif
justement de lutte contre le terrorisme
et de la présence française au sahel se
trouve au mali il y à un risque évident
que le mali deviennent à nouveau un
sanctuaire du djihad un sanctuaire 2 à
partir duquel ces groupes pourraient
frapper d'autres pays le niger et les
pays du golfe de guinée
[Musique]